معارك ضاريه تشهدها مدينه بخموت منذ
اسابيع لم تحسن بعد لكن احتدام الوضع فيها
لم يغفي العيون موسكو يوما عن واجهه
اوكرانيا نحو البحر الاسود اوديسا
اليوم تزداد مخاوف اوكرانيا من شن روسيا
هجوما مباغتا من جهه الغرب اي من اقليم
ترانسنيستريا المولدوفي الذي تتمركز فيه
قوات روسيه خصوصا بعد ان اعلن مستشار
الرئيس الاداره العسكريه في اوديسا تسريع
وتيره عمليات تحصين المدينه لمنع تعرضها
لهجوم حده التوتر تصاعدت على حدود هذا
الاقليم بعد ان اعلن الجيش الاوكراني ان
روسيا تنشر سفنا اضافيه بما في ذلك خمس
حاملات صواريخ وغواصتان في البحر الاسود
خطوه روسيا العسكريه بحريا ارفقتها
بالتهامات لقياف بتحضيرها استفزازا عسكريا
ضد اقليم ترانسينيستريا هذه الاتهامات
كانت كفيله بتعزيز فرضيه التوجه الروسي
لاطلاق مرحله جديده من الصراع بمشاركه
الانفصاليين المندويين الموالين لموسكو
اهميه فتح هذه الجبهه تكمن بالسعي الى
تعقيد الموقف اكثر امام كييف من خلال
توسيع رقعه المواجهات من ناحيه والعمل
بشكل مباشر على محاوله السيطره على ميناء
اوديسا في اقصى غربي البلاد من ناحيه اخرى